it's good to be bad it's even better to
go from bad to good this is the
unwritten law of anime where we all root
for a villain who has a change of heart
and joins the cause of the right and
just the anime universe is chock-full of
characters who aren't villains to the
bitter end but rather rogues and
scoundrels on first impression it might
be their actions impulsive or otherwise
justifiable or not it might be their
personality that makes them antagonistic
and evil even if that's not their true
intention it might be a difficult past
the scars of which they need to be
rescued from naturally there comes a
time when they shed their animosity and
go over to the bright side and when that
happens all sins are forgiven and past
indiscretions forgotten just like that
so in today's video let's count down the
top 10 anime good guys who started off
bad and cheer them on as they transform
into the champions guardians and
protectors we've all come to love and
admire
appearances can be deceptive to be clear
through a talented Esper and arguably
mobs first rival isn't the dictionary
definition of bad his problem is that he
is supremely arrogant and has a hugely
inflated ego thanks to his academic
brilliance popularity with his peers and
his psychic abilities he thinks quite
mistakenly
that the world revolves around him and
there's no one quite like him now this
proud peacock has his delusional dream
shattered into a million pieces
when mob beats the socks pants and every
other item of clothing off him from then
on Thoreau is a changed boy and not just
because he loses half of his hair in the
fight humbled by defeat he even begins
to emulate mob adopting his code of not
using psychic powers to hurt others
defeat also teaches through the meaning
of vulnerability a valuable life lesson
he might still have a little trouble
being modest but we definitely like him
better now even when his hair sometimes
resembles a stack of hay
we all loved watching anime but how
about taking it a step further with one
of the best anime MMORPGs in town let me
introduce you to the sponsors of this
video or a kingdom or a kingdoms are
free to play MMORPG that allows the
player to take the role of the envoi of
Gaia with its engaging story the player
then gets to explore azureus various
colourful regions fighting monsters and
solving multiple problems along the way
now at first I expected getting myself
into the typical anime MMO but aura
Kingdom just blew me away with just how
much you can do the staples such as
dungeons pets skill trees and so are
there however aura Kingdom features some
of the best and most well-designed pet
systems that I've known in an MMO in
addition there are a whopping 16 classes
to choose from - feel free to experience
the game from all angles the options are
just staggering aura Kingdom with its
enormous range of options for costumes
mounts and pets can provide that escape
you need from the stressful days so what
are you waiting for click the link in
the description and come and join the
fun and hop into the colorful world of
Azeri with aura Kingdom growing the
second punch is Hajime no Ippo smushy
Barrio who looks every bit the villain
he is at least in the first arc of this
boxing anime
they call him Shinigami or death God an
alias earned by beating multiple
opponents into retirement and it's easy
to see why his skills are off the charts
in the ring his hitman stance and killer
jab are legendary but it's his penchant
to play dirty that makes him extra nasty
he thinks nothing of foot stomps and
head butts to get out of a sticky
situation
out of the ring - my Shiva is hostile
rude and unsociable when his sister
goomy throws him a celebratory party she
realizes he doesn't have a single friend
so what redeems him what for one he's
fiercely protective of Kumi who has
looked out for from a young age after
their parents death he has a genuine
love for boxing that's a pleasure to
watch and he has the social skills of a
slug which makes him easily
misunderstood and that much more
relatable he's a diamond in the rough
well that might be taking things a
little bit too far but it suffice to say
my Sheba is not the devil
moving on to number eight is Nishiki
mashiki is a model student and devoted
boyfriend by day but night reveals his
true identity a gold that eats humans
that's not what makes him bad though all
girls do that since this is the only way
for them to survive but Nishiki is a
ruthless violent rebel without a cause
who kills for sport
he shows no loyalty to humans or goals
and can just as easily kill his own kind
if they trespass on his feeding grounds
he's not above sadistic tricks either as
he shows when he takes heed a hostage to
target Carnegie even his relationship
with Kimmi his human girlfriend is
dishonest and selfish given that he's
willing to use her as food when his
fight with Connect he leaves him wounded
and unable to hunt
Nishiki is the way he is because a
family tragedy destroyed his trust in
others and turned him into a lone wolf
even then it's hard to imagine him
giving up his bloodlust adjusting to a
life without killing and living in
harmony with humans and ghouls but
that's what happens he does remain
foul-mouthed and hot-tempered as ever
though you can't have everything now can
you
Academy City strongest Esper makes the
cut at number seven the pale-faced
Whitehead accelerators not only aloof
and unfriendly he's a willing
participant in what appears to be a
highly unethical experiment that
requires him to kill thousands of clones
to raise his own power level quite
unnecessary given that his psychic
ability one-way road is immense
accelerators transformation begins when
he's defeated by kamijou touma
a regular student with no psychic powers
except for a mysterious ability to
negate any supernatural attack
accelerators loss also spells the end of
the experiment his metamorphosis is
complete when he meets his ward last
order a clone like one of the thousands
he's killed in a remarkable change the
cold-hearted teenager is now willing to
endanger his own life in order to save
hers we later find out accelerators
motive for joining the experiment was to
power up to such a level that no one
would dare challenge him and be
destroyed by his powers since the switch
to mr. nice-guy
accelerators even got his own side story
in the magical franchise of which he's
the chief protagonist
next up is veeral from gurren lagaan v
val is a member of the beast men a clan
of humanoids that rule the world by
terrorizing humankind a recurring
villain for quite a bit of this
acclaimed series VI allah considers the
free-spirited Garman are his biggest
rival and would do anything to defeat
him even if it means a joining forces
with just about anyone willing to take
on the leader of team guy Guren and his
brother saman sadly for him his efforts
almost always end in failure despite his
sinister appearance and obsession with
da minha BL has some honorable even
redeeming qualities while he hates to
lose he won't stand for victory at the
cost of his pride and honour he's
empathetic to even those who treat him
poorly and his enquiring mind makes him
question the orders he's given rather
than just follow them blindly so given
the way he is it's no surprise that he
eventually becomes one of the good guys
after being saved by saman via rail not
only joins team Dai Guren on the
former's request but succeeds governor
as the pilot a wonderful tribute indeed
to a foreign rival he always admired
[Music]
next is Frankie from one piece where do
we start about the next entry on this
list before he became animes most
superhero in underpants and the
shipwright ingenious inventor of the
straw hat pirates this seafaring cyborg
was a bit of a Yakuza style gangster in
the water 7 arctor introduces his
character Frankie and his ship breaking
crude not only steal the straw hats and
money which they need for a new ship but
also beat us off to a pulp the usually
cheerful Asaf is already pretty
miserable over the fact that his beloved
Mary can no longer sail seeing him
treated this way watching him beg for
the money and then despair over his own
weakness makes us hate Frankie's guts
all that much he totally deserved to
have Robin perform her clutch move on
his crown jewels
during his initiation into the crew
that's definitely for sure
of course a Frankie makes up for his
early mistakes by building the straw
hats the ship of their dreams a worthy
successor to marry these days at
Frankie's better known for his cool
hairstyles dazzling laser beams and
giving the Marines endless headaches by
breaking into dr. Vega Punk's lab but
who could forget that this lovable Hulk
was once the catalyst
straw hats greatest internal crisis
our next candidate so wannabe
singer-songwriter musician cat lover and
foster son of an ancient dragon God
you'll read for the Iron Dragon Slayer
has bad boy written all over him from
his long spiky hair to the piercings on
his face and body these days he's busy
fighting dark forces protecting his girl
and bickering with fellow Dragon Slayer
Natsu he's strong loyal reliable and
friendly although a tad bit grumpy for
as long as we can remember he's been one
of the pillars of fairy tale but rewind
to the beginning of the series and our
favorite irony - actually starts off
pretty bad then a member of phantom Lord
Guardian leads an attack on Fairy Tail
destroys its guild hall and attacks its
weakest members in the worst possible
way there's no strong motive behind his
actions other than the fact that he's
taking down the competition and this is
perhaps why he readily accepts Fairy
Tail Master Makarov offered to join the
guild after he soundly defeated by not
soup though guy - your sense of
comradeship eventually grows strong and
deep there are those who still view him
as disloyal and opportunistic such as
the dark guild Raven Tail gajeel uses
this to his advantage as he successfully
infiltrates Raven tail on Makarov orders
sometimes a bad rep isn't all that bad
taking the number three spot is scar of
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
the villain of circumstance but a
villain or the same scars of vigilante
and killer who targets state alchemists
a survivor of the issue a civil war his
actions are driven by his hatred of
alchemists who massacred his people and
destroyed his homeland
now this blind hatred at times makes him
attack innocents who have no connection
to his troubled history scars of
physical strength intelligence and
thirst for vengeance make him a
dangerous opponent to even the most
skilled alchemists and despite his
fundamental opposition to alchemy his
right hand possesses a strain of alchemy
that lays to waste anything it touches
as his arch nemesis Kimberly puts it all
this man knows how to do is destroy what
makes Skye even more fearsome is his
belief that he's bringing God's wrath
upon his enemies but even in his crazed
pursuit of revenge
he shows glimpses of his former kind of
self for instance his uncharacteristic
response to May's little panda or the
way ed and Al's relationship reminds him
of his dead brother and makes him soften
just that tiny little bit when he
ultimately starts looking at things
without his veil of hatred the
alchemists find in Skaar a potent ally
in their battle against the evil
homunculus
taking the number-2 spot is the guy who
had us all fooled into thinking he was
the devil spawn before he became the
benevolent Gaza car guy and Naruto's
friend Gaara was a creepy 12 year old
who exuded menace with his dark rimmed
green eyes bristly red hair and
permanent scowl in childhood the sand
shinobi is the complete foil to Naruto
if Naruto's a ray of sunshine he's a
dark strong cloud the Chunin exam mark
introduces Gaara as the series first
villain who's at the same age as its
lovable hero because he has the one
tailed beast shukaku sealed inside him
Gaara is shunned by his father feared by
his siblings and too tested by his
people alone who sworn to love only
himself he's hostile to any and all he's
powerful and not afraid to use that
power to hurt others he shows no remorse
neither does he show mercy even to those
weaker than him friendships and human
bonds mean little to him all that
changes though when he meets Naruto for
those of us who've grown up with this
shown in classic we now know Gaara to be
strong responsible gentle and
mild-mannered he's a skilled ninja an
inspiring leader a steadfast friend and
a loyal ally he's also popular with the
ladies
seeing him now you almost forget the
young child filled with animosity in a
war with the whole world
we've reached the end of the line and
it's time to reveal our number one pick
just remember that there's an ocean of
difference between him and all the
others on this list as such his journey
to the good side is the most fascinating
by far he's a prince and heir to one of
the strongest warrior races in the
planet he's also done things few
full-time villains have achieved in
their lifetimes which includes kicking
the person who's healed you beating up
your kid for no good reason
selling your soul for power nearly
getting your wife and son killed
finishing off half-dead opponents
killing a comrade who's been by your
side since you're a kid murdering
innocents again and again and again and
destroying an entire planet just for the
fun of it
he is Vegeta Super Saiyan and super bad
there's no points for guessing Vegeta
might be one of the good guys now but
through the Dragon Ball franchise's long
ride he's s8 every other role imaginable
villain antihero even comic relief if
you recall his infamous moustache in
Dragon Ball GT not that up as one of his
crimes along with being smug cocky
elitist and arrogant Vegeta's list of
evil deeds sometimes crosses the line of
criminal stupidity like when he allows
cell to achieve his perfect form only to
then be taken down by that form he might
have eventually ended up as the perfect
family man at Earth's great champion but
he's still no angel and never will be
and there you have it the top 10 anime
good guys who started off bad I hope you
enjoyed watching this video as much as I
did making it give it a like if you did
you can also drop me a line and tell me
what you think of this selection or if
there are characters that you think
should be on this list
let's have a conversation about it don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
aura Kingdom the links in the
description ciao
[Music]